the latest god of war introduces a
surprising number of changes to the
series it does away with the linear
structure and progression from past
games now you can explore an open-ended
environment earn XP to unlock abilities
from a skill tree and even earn armor
sets that improve your stats suffice to
say there are a lot of systems in place
this time around and it can get
overwhelming trying to manage it all at
first
that's why we've compiled together all
the major details on god of wars systems
and mechanics to help you get a better
understanding of its progression let's
start with character upgrades god of war
slowly introduces you to its mechanics
encouraging you to explore and pick up
resources scattered around the world but
for reasons not quite stated as you
progress it's revealed that the
resources you pick up can be used at
shops to purchase an upgrade crate OSes
equipment there are a variety of
different avenues to upgrade and
strengthen Kratos init Reyes the four
main ways are through armor sets
enchantments axe pommels and talismans
armour plays a big part in God of War
not only for increasing your stats to
improve your chances of survival but for
specializing in traits that you value in
combat for example if you like using
runic attacks you should equip armor
that increases runic attack damage take
time to think about what statistics you
value the most and stick with them as
the sooner you can funnel your resources
into crafting and upgrading the armor
that best supports that the better the
same philosophy applies to at Reyes at
the blacksmith shop you can buy him
armor sets that enhances characteristics
in different ways for instance once set
increases his arrow damage while another
improves the damage he does when
strangling enemies at Reyes can be
incredibly effective in battle so it's
important to think about which Armour
set best suits how you want to use them
enchantments are special accessories
that you can slot into your armor that
further enhance their stats each piece
of armor can hold at least one
enchantment as long as it has an
available socket if an armor piece
doesn't have any you can unlock sockets
by upgrading them at the blacksmith shop
throughout your journey you'll get your
hands on a ton of enchantments so always
make sure to check your inventory to see
if there are any that you should replace
from your current loadout oftentimes an
enchantment has a special perk that
gives you attack buffs and resistances
that are either inherent or activate
randomly during battle while it's useful
to be aware of enchantment perks you'll
generally want to focus on equipping
ones that best increase your stats as
they give you the most significant boost
compared to other items in the game it's
important to note that whenever you
purchase a new armor set make sure to
react whip all of the enchantments from
your old armor on to your new one unless
you're a fan of playing at a
disadvantage don't make this mistake
axé Paul moles are special items that
further increase the Leviathan axes
power similar to enchantments they offer
perks that activate either randomly or
after you perform a specific action in
battle for example the deadly grip of
fury has a perk that grants your rage
burst after a successful axe kill since
you can only equip a single axe pummel
you generally want to lean towards the
ones with the best perks as they often
don't offer the most substantial stat
boosts but the choice is up to you
you're not punished for focusing on
stats / perks
Talisman's are accessories that you can
equip that allow you to perform a
special ability in battle they come in
two varieties active and passive active
talismans can be triggered manually by
pressing a special button combination
passive talismans are activated by
performing a specific action in battle
like dodging an attack at the last
second
while talismans also offer boosts to
your stats you'll generally want to
focus on equipping one that best suits
your needs in battle for example if
you'd like to have a little insurance
when nearing death the talisman of
concentrated vitality allows you to
manually give yourself a health boost
mid battle by pressing l1 in the circle
button it's best to be practical when it
comes to choosing a talisman their stat
boosts may provide an initiative to
equip one over the other but it's their
perks that are most important as they
can directly impact and change the tide
of battle
moving on to god of War's combat you'll
find it to be fairly limited at first
but once you start acquiring more skills
and runic attacks battles start to
become more complex enemies only get
tougher as the game goes on so it helps
that there are ways to defend yourself
the first way to increase your strength
in combat is by unlocking abilities in
the skill tree with the XP you earn in
battle skills are generally new combat
moves like combos charging attacks and
active attack buffs
both Kratos and at Reyes have their own
skills you can upgrade you don't earn a
lot of XP early on so it's important to
start thinking about which skills best
suit your playstyle but don't fret
you're not forced to unlock certain
scales over others of the whole way
through you'll eventually nab enough XP
to unlock every ability on the skill
tree until then choose your skills
wisely while you might be inclined to
utilize the default attacks and combos
available to you to dispatch foes don't
forget to use your runic attacks
these powerful special moves can be
equipped to your weapons and are
triggered by holding l1 and pressing r1
or r2 there are two types of runic
attacks light and heavy the game
features a variety of different runic
attacks to equip each sporting their own
unique effects attributes and cooldowns
it is possible to upgrade runic attacks
with XP to enhance their power
you might feel inclined to upgrade
combat skills over them but don't
underestimate how they can aid you in
battle a well-placed runic attack can
give you the upper hand when your
chances of survival seem low upgrading
runic attacks improves their damage stun
and overall capability do not forget to
use and upgrade them they're well worth
it and that's all you need to know about
god of War's progression system tells
probably a lot to take in so if you have
any additional questions leave them in
the comments below but if you're looking
for more tips on how to get started be
sure to watch our God of War beginners
guide thanks for watching
[Music]